it's pretty obvious what kind of culture
they're attempting to build here it's a
culture of censorious righteousness
important as she says
that actually tolerates actual porn
right you have to understand that what
they're acting in defense of
is not a a counter culture what they're
acting in defense of is an anti-culture
that tears away all traditional
standards and so anybody who is a
defender of any element of traditional
standards up to and including
your individual right to offend that
must be torn down too
it is important that anything that
smacks of the old ways
and the old ways is not just you know
two-parent
household the white picket fence and the
two
two and a half kids it's not just that
the old ways include your ability to
offend anyone if you offend anyone
then this means that you must be cast
out into the outer work into the outer
realms you
have to be wished into the cornfield
this is why the grammys
right it's it's hard to square right
when when you watched any of the grammys
last night which i don't know who did
the ratings probably were garbage but
when you watch the grammys which is made
for blue check marks on twitter there
were two competing
visions that were really at odds one was
bill burr said a thing
and the thing was unwoke and this means
that bill burr is bad
and he must trend and he has cancelled
because we must never
allow anything like what bilber said to
be said ever again not in a public space
guys
bill burr has to be stopped he's a
comedian and he violated
our sense of propriety he our puritanism
the new puritans
are great with porn and very bad with
political
dissidents and if you disagree with them
then that then you must be burned at the
stake
but if you want to simulate lesbian sex
acts on stage in front of millions of
people then
not only is that good that is wonderful
for our culture right so bilber
he gets up and he makes a joke because
why the hell
and he's right he's he was there to
introduce
the best latino or latina artist or
something
and bill burr's like why am i doing this
i'm like i'm a white guy you can see all
the feminists
out there already complaining about
here's what bill burr had to say and
then he trended for this
was i the only one who wanted to kill
himself during that piano solo
um i bought a suit for this i thought it
was going to be on tv i'm such a
i am losing so much money right now and
the winner
uh the grammy goes to natalya la for
caddy
dude oh i will look oh sorry i will
accept on behalf
of her if i butchered her name i'm sorry
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts
why is this this white male doing all
this latino stuff
okay and people on the world club were
like it's true why is that white male
doing all this latino stuff and then
commenting on it
how dare he laughing about butchering
people's names how dare he right this is
where the puritanism comes out
because our cultural puritans can never
allow bill burr to make a joke about his
own inability to pronounce
latino names you can let sorry latinx
names
right you can never make a joke about
that is which burning stuff right he
must be he must be burned
bilberry is a bad man because he is cis
and he's
white where the h comes before the w
white
right he is a very very bad man but you
know what is great for our culture what
is great for our culture is harry styles
waraboa
because he was doing a bad david bowie
impersonation from 1986 from 1983
and and then what is also fantastic
fantastic for our culture
is extraordinarily graphic simulated
lesbian sex acts on stage
for the brand new artist of the year
megan v stallion her given name
her parents decided that her middle name
had to be v not with one
e which would make sense she'd be megan
thus stalling megan the stallion you
are the stallion okay not just you
are
megan v the be a stallion okay so she
and cardi b simulated like full-on
pornographic act
and this has been the shtick for a while
right i mean going all the way back to
madonna let's not pretend this is
anything new the simulated sex acts on
stage at the grammys
has been quite a thing for several
decades but this was
i will say uniquely graphic right so
here was a little bit
of what happened at the grammys remember
our new puritans are great with with
porn
and infecting the culture with debauched
behavior they are fantastic with this
right they are the same people who will
say that whap is an empire in a deeply
empowering feminist song because nothing
says empowerment
quite like rapping about the moisture
state of your genitals for the pleasure
of men to consume your actual
content that that is feminism up the
wazoo
tremendous levels of feminism that is
great for our culture but if i ran the
zoo has to go guys
if i ran the zoo is deeply dangerous for
your kids if your kids
read about the island of mazurka
with a bird called the yurka your kids
will be ruined for life
deeply disturbed for life but if you
give your kid puberty blockers at
the age of five so they can decide their
gender at the age of 13 and if you
infuse the culture with a bunch of
warmed over soft core pornography on the
grammys
and then call it high culture that's not
bad for the culture that's good for the
culture this is like shakespeare
it's amazing now listen i'm not sure
that there is a
deep connection between the quality of
art that a culture produces and the
morality of the culture right german
culture produced some wonderful highs
but i will say this
i have yet to see a culture that
produces low art and pretends that it is
high
art that is worthwhile right that is not
a thing that
so just because the culture produces
high art doesn't mean the culture is
good
but just because a culture produces low
art and that becomes the height of art
that's a pretty good indicator that you
have a culture and decline this is a
culture and decline right here
and people cheering then a woman dancing
uh inside of a of a
a box in which cash is being blown at
her this is high culture guys
this is the height of our culture so if
i round the zoo very bad for your kids
don't no no if around the zoo huck finn
terrible for your children mark twain
has to go shakespeare is sexist
shakespeare is racist shakespeare is old
fashioned
our new culture however has amazing
things like this
like showing on major national
television
in the evening time full-on simulated
lesbian pornography
well done everyone like just i feel our
culture is in great hands
and by the way if you make a joke about
it you ought to be canceled if you make
a joke about it
then we ought to go after your
advertisers and get you fired okay i'm
sorry but this new puritanism is not
going to stand
because it is garbage it is not even
puritanism on behalf
of some purported higher consonants with
the universe or something
it is not like i'm trying to get in
touch with deeper values i'm trying to
get in touch with my god and i can't do
that and while these people are
dissenting that's bad enough
right theocracy is bad but this is just
theocracy
on behalf of pagan garbage okay this is
theocracy on behalf of pornography which
is a very weird form
of theocracy it's just paganism and that
pagan culture
will brook no dissent everyone must be
ruined and if you cross the woke pagan
culture
then you must be destroyed i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content